[Applause]  doctor tryna stay with Durant knocks it  away in Durant's Lincoln grant goes down  holding his leg he boxer goes up and his  style down the other end  and Durant grabbing that right leg  [Applause]  it's the right calf put them out  his teammates going over to check on him  [Applause]  I don't like to hear the fans out  cheering I'm surprised by that in and  the players are telling him not to be  doing that no question these Raptor fans  have been wonderful but to cheer for a  player who gets injured the credit serge  ibaka there's the play right away he  knew it you will not see a better sight  than we just witnessed unfortunately  what happened to Kevin Durant but Kyle  Lowry Pascal siakam Serge Ibaka telling  the crowd no we are not gonna cheer when  this guy goes down that's appreciation  for greatness  [Applause]